now your mom
i'm told is concerned about what you
might say about her tonight is she
concerned when you discuss her when
you're doing interviews she's terrified
that i'm going to come on like a late
night show
and talk about her and say terrible
things about her which i would never do
even though she's
crazy
my mom is nuts your mom is nuts but i
would never really go out and say
something
awful about her like what kind of thing
um like
uh i don't know like recently oh uh
recently my favorite thing that i'd like
to
kind of river for is
you know i did wet hot american summer
yeah and so oh did you like that show
um
and so she said
i started to make a list because she
would call and say
i saw a nice review for rock and roll
summer camp
she called she called it young's what
she called it young sweaty americans one
time
she never once said wet hot american
she's in a way very creative my mom
can't get the title straight of this
show
um
let's talk about casual um
uh there's it's such a good show so many
people were talking about it there are
sex scenes which can
you know by television standards can be
a little bit on the graphic side do you
warn your family if your mom's you know
you're worried about your mom or your
parents or anybody oh yeah siblings
what do you do well we're not the kind
of family we're like you know hey
you know sex pass the butter we're like
um we don't talk about this business
wow that was sexy what you just did
hot butter
that's some pretty hot talk around the
table more i guess it depends on what
you do with the butter
[Applause]
that is true
um or a canola oil yeah um
but no we no it's just i just mean we
don't we don't talk about sex in our
house it's very we're very repressed in
a really great fun lovable way um
so yeah you know i had one scene that i
wrote an email to my entire family and
said if you want to protect your psyche
just don't watch the last
four minutes of episode three of casual
and everybody wrote back i watched it
like that
i watched it i watched it first they
wanted a prize i think they wanted a
little like a reward like i watched you
have fake sex yeah i did it yeah you're
welcome
but you were cool with it you're fine
with them seeing no i'm not cool with it
it's horrible i i'm i love